it was not obvious at all but he's just
getting out of those night forks that we
mentioned earlier
and uh yeah maybe we'll see the rest of
the pawns start to disappear and uh
magnus just under 10 seconds on the
clock
and uh it does look like three seconds
that was incredible yeah but it does
seem like the position is kind of
fizzing out now there aren't too many
pawns on the board but
is there a question about black's king
has magnitude
across giving a tractor look at his face
the black light falls off there we go
he's just blunders complete blunder
wow magnus self destructs he just loses
his knight on the next move
and he runs once again
against magnus
pragnanda he beats magnus carlson again
what just happened
it's the type of one-move blunder that
we're not used to seeing from magnus but
he has creeped into his game in the last
year or so
just one moment i mean it was a dead
draw almost too ivanka was saying
everything was disappearing off the
board it was pretty much